- Yamaneika,
J.P. Are we ready?
[cheers and applause]
- Let's roast!
- So, Comedy Central
has screwed me again.
They gave me another boring
white guy to roast.
I had to Google him.
Google told me to go to Bing.
Bing told me
to go to Ask Jeeves.
Ask Jeeves said, "I don't know
who this [bleep] is."
- That's pretty good.
First of all, just--
I want to say what an honor it
is for me to be here
with some icons of comedy.
I mean, Jay Pharoah, Jim Norton,
Cedric the Entertainer.
[laughter]
There are a lot of great
comics in New York,
but truly Yamaneika
really is one of the loudest.
- J.P. is a Catholic
Wall Street banker.
The only thing whiter
and slimier
than him is the [bleep] on his
back from Father O'Brien.
[siren wailing]
- I knew this was gonna be
a tough battle 'cause, like,
we look like we're on
opposite ends of the fire hose.
Let me just say, though,
Yamaneika is so dark
she got cast in
"12 Years a Slave" as the plot.
- Last joke! Last joke!
- J.P. is from Newtown,
Connecticut,
where the Sandy Hook
tragedy happened.
And the worst thing
that happened to that town
is that he wasn't
seven years old
at the time of the shooting.
[all exclaim]
[gunshots]
- Oh! Oh!
- Got your ass.
- Okay, okay.
Thank you, Fat Thighs Matter.
- Oh, shit.
- Yamaneika grew up in a White
suburban town in Maryland.
Her nickname in high school
was [gasps].
[bell dings]
- Hey, keep it going
for J.P. McDade
and Yamaneika Saunders.
- So much fun.
Super-close.
- I have to say,
both really great.
Yamaneika had
a great--that Sandy Hook
joke was brutal
and really great.
And you were great firing back.
But J.P., I thought
the hose joke was brilliant.
I had to go with J.P.
You're kind of creepy
and suburban,
but you're really funny.
- Thank you. Thank you.
- This is exciting.
This is like
watching Leslie Jones
take on one of her
Internet trolls.
- I love that. I love that.
- You both were [bleep] amazing,
but I got to give it to J.P.
on the cleverness.
The [bleep] jokes were amazing.
J.P.
- Interesting.
- That's two for J.P., Jeff.
- See, this surprises me
because I thought Yamaneika
won this thing when she said,
"Got you ass" and spun around.
I thought it was
pretty much over.
My vote's for Yamaneika.
- I honestly loved both of you.
I have to tell you,
he's like a Jeselnik
in that he's that sharp
and mean and nasty,
but you like him anyway.
Now, her. I like this bitch,
and I have to vote for--
you're both--
this is by a [bleep] hair.
I have to give it to you,
the black girl.
I forgot your name
but you're terrif--
- Yes! Yamaneika.
- Yamaneika.
- Name yourself something normal
like a [bleep] white person.
So, I say vote
for the black chick.
Come on, clap it up for her.
- Thank you.
- It's tied up.
- Uh-oh.
- It all comes down to you,
ex-SNL cast member Jay Pharoah.
- God dag it. Okay.
I got ADD but shit. Okay.
I would have to say--
[exhales]
Don't get mad at me, baby.
- Oh, [bleep] man.
- Yamaneika.
Bow. I would say--see?
Look. I deceived y'all
[bleep].
You see? Yamaneika.
I would say--
- Oh, yeah?
- Yeah, you, [bleep]. You.
- Oh!
- I would say you.
- Yamaneika!
- I'm gonna keep battling
Yamaneika until I win.
Or I'm just gonna try
to exact revenge
for the rest of my life.
This affection that you see
right here,
at least on my part,
100% an act.
Not real at all.
- Yeah. Ladies, he's mine.
I'm gonna eat him.
- Help.
Please--please send help.
- [laughs]